il est le cerveau présumé du massacre du
7 octobre en Israël yayassin noir chef
du Hamas dans la bande de Gaza est la
cible numéro 1 que l'État hébreu traque
depuis 30 ans selon le ministre de la
défense israélienne il se terre dans les
entrailles de Gaza yayassin noir est
connu depuis longtemps des services
israéliens son chef aurait même
recommandé de le faire assassiner à
l'été 2021 l'histoire de yayassin noir
débute en 1962 dans le camp de réfugiés
de canyunes après que ses parents
Palestiniens ont été chassés par la
première guerre israélo-arabe il grandit
dans le même quartier que Mohamed deif
le futur commandant de la branche armée
du Hamas pour qui l'occupation
israélienne nourrit rage et désespoir
dès 1985 yay sinoir est chargé de
traquer les taupes qui collabore avec
Israël et en 1987 quand le Hamas est
créé sur le serment de lutter contre
l'occupant israélien il s'engage sans
hésiter 2 ans plus tard alors qu'il est
incarcéré dans une prison israélienne il
finit par avouer sa participation à
l'écriture d'une charte qui prône la
destruction d'Israël son implication
dans la fabrication d'enjin explosif et
son rôle dans l'exécution de 12
Palestiniens soupçonnés de collaboration
selon les renseignements israéliens au
cours de ses quatre séjours en prison
sin noir s'impose vite comme le chef
incontesté du Hamas il avait le meurtre
dans les yeux à Gaza certains
Palestiniens l'avaient surnommé le
boucher de canones en 2011 sinoir est
libéré lors d'une négociation de
libération de prisonniers mais il faut
attendre février 2017 lorsqu'il é élu
chef du bureau politique du Hamas pour
qu'il monte en puissance si on m'avait
demandé mon avis je n'aurais jamais
accepté qu'il soit relâché à regrettter
un retraité du cineb qu'il le
connaissait de près Yassine noir
commence alors à assurer qu'il souhaite
résoudre pacifiquement le conflit sans
causer de druction et les généraux
israéliens semblent se laisser ramadouer
sinir a endordu l'armée en répétant que
sa priorité était de développer Casa
avec l'aide de l'Iran il a mis ce temps
à profit pour muscler les capacités
militaires de ses forces spéciales
résultat il a dû observer de près les
divisions qui rongeaient notre société
et se dire que nous ne serions pas
capable de réagir en cas d'attaque hélas
pour les Palestiniens il s'est
lourdement trompé le 7 octobre il a
certes été capable de nous infliger une
cicatrice indélbile mais aux yeux de son
peuple il demeurera surtout comme
l'homme qui a déclenché une seconde
lacba